i wasn't a physical specimen like him
not
or a physical mess like
but the difference is unless he takes me
out early
i kill him
because i will be trying as are to kill
him in the 12th round as i'm trying in
the first technically i'm not as good
i'm certainly not as heavy-handed but if
he doesn't get me out of there i'm the
type person that turns into your worst
nightmare because i don't talk about
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm eddie hearn and i'm barry hearn and
this is legends for sports bible it's
actually my bit i know it was
eddie who is pound for pound the best
boxer on the planet right now
well
it has to be obviously matron promoted
one of our clients undisputed super
middleweight world champion canelo
alvarez
i don't think there's anyone on this
planet could disagree with you just just
done that eddie so obviously the one
loss he's got in his record is to floyd
mayweather
but
do you think this canelo wouldn't beat
the floyd made up whether that beat him
at the time
it's a tough question you know we talk
about floyd mayweather against canelo
alvarez because floyd was so difficult
to beat
but at the same time i think canelo
alvarez was 21 22 when he fought him so
he is
twice the fighter he was then
could he beat floyd mayweather in his
prime i think so
what is the proudest moment of your
career so far
watching my son change the face of
boxing oh believe me not i just put it
all right i was just scared i was proud
the proudest moment of my career
i know this is going to sound right
old-fashioned and we're in a trendy
society but
i think getting my ob from prince
charles at windsor castle
was right up there
as a fulfillment did you know you
already mentioned it
well you know i'm not that type i'm not
the pushy type but
no
that was i think my proudest moment of
my career so far
shortly to be followed by the knighthood
and eventually the kingdom right
what's your opinion on youtuber boxing
because that surely is your next person
i've done it i've done it i've done the
biggest fight that can be made in
youtube no i was talking about you
participate right yeah
yeah i was thinking about fighting jake
paul i sort of had a bit of banza for
him i was hoping that he'd buy it and i
was like hey never know could be
fighting me next i was hoping he'd go
would you take that and he went
i went yeah
so i'm not getting involved in any more
youtube boxing jake paul's not really
youtube boxing anymore he's actually
he's fine probably but how far do you
think he can go jake not very far about
as far as he's gone but you know he's
he's a big lump he can punch a little
bit and
you know he's putting the timing in the
camps so we'll see
have you ever tried your hand at boxing
i know you have but they've asked me to
ask the question billericky boxing club
eddie hills as they know me still
undefeated still absolutely useless but
you said i was like a jack in the box no
no i said you was like a pair of braces
out of control
just pinned up and down on the spot it
was really quite a zebedee like magic
roundabout
but with gloves on
so why do they know you as eddie hills
because
i didn't notice at the time but when i
was getting intro in the fight they
called me eddie hills the first time i
thought was a mistake and then the
second fight that i had i asked him
about it and he said that he'd asked him
to call me hills because he didn't want
him to know that i was hearn because
then they'd beat the guitar
did it work
no i still
what did barry think when eddie said he
wanted to follow in your footsteps oh
well
i was very obviously i'm pleased i'm a
i'm a dad i want you the best for my
kids and uh i don't want to get serious
on an interview like this but i've
always been proud of you and i always
knew you'd be good
maybe nearly as good as me who do you
think will next be the undisputed
heavyweight champion next i mean it's
gonna be obviously
tyson fury against dillian white and aj
against usyk so the winners of those are
back aj all day long i believe he's
gonna beat usyk in the rematch and then
i believe the momentum and that's gonna
see him beat the winner off fury against
wyatt when eddie is in trouble do you
call him edward
yes no you don't
no your mother tom does yeah yeah yeah
she's the only person that calls me
edward and a little story on that is
where my mates used to call me pre
mobile phone days they'd phone the house
phone
if mum picked it up she goes hello there
is eddie there please yes no problem one
sec
edward
yeah just just my mum barry when was the
last time you had to tell her the off oh
it's difficult
we're not a normal family we don't
actually tell each other off we take the
of each other that's our way of telling
off so if he does a show that loses
money i don't tell him off but i
ridiculed him eddie
what do you rate as your best
celebrity impression okay i'll go eubank
and it would be something like
barry it is amazing to see you looking
so
sartorially blessed today i mean i'll be
honest the jacket doesn't really fit but
it doesn't matter because you had a big
weekend of the food didn't you and we
know that you are deep down a warrior
and the warrior code is instilled within
you
who else have you got in your looker
so canelo alvarez you know payday
you won't pay the i know that i know
that get the [ __ ] out of here man so now
i go be honest
not a good start
we're talking to the hearns here be
honest how often does eddie watch no
context her and clips
that's a good question i follow him so
it's on my feed non-stop and whenever
there's a major incident
do not think in the bigger picture of
your own self-promotion which as we all
know is humongous that that's actually
been a major relationship so much so the
people that know me well yeah sometimes
go to me
you're behind that aren't you and i i'm
not i'm definitely
if i wasn't
when it came out there is a chance by
now i would have been behind it yeah so
thank you andy who created that account
who is the better sportsman eddie or
barry
when it comes to enthusiasm i am a
different gravy
[Laughter]
but when it comes to ability
i generally come second i've got him on
a couple of things number one is all the
older main really athletic sports yeah
marathons excuse me is that not a main
athletic sport
i mean my best marathon time is three
hours twenty two two and your best
marathon time
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna give you some
sports now guys yeah and i want you to
tell me who would be the better sports
person in their prime yeah you're in
their prime brian barry prime medic so
boxing
i think me
because you're like i've seen pictures
of you when you were young
and you were like ten stone ringing wet
and you're always like you know when i
was young i tell you what yeah
i look at pictures of you and think no
don't give it that i mean i was useless
but well you weren't useless you were
average
um
the difference is it's where you come
from you see i wasn't a physical
specimen like him
[Laughter]
or a physical mess like
but the difference is unless he takes me
out early
i kill him
because i will be trying as hard to kill
him in the 12th round as i'm trying in
the first technically i'm not as good
i'm certainly not as heavy-handed but if
he doesn't get me out of there i'm the
type person that turns into your worst
nightmare because i don't talk about
i think she's a press conference
what about golf
me
i think he's got better hands than me
so his short game is better and he's got
the power to drive the ball as far as
top pros really when he hits it most of
the time you can't find it
which is an advantage but no i'd have to
give him the golf okay in barry's
opinion who is the most talented sports
person he has ever worked with
oh
the talent most talented
you know when you talk about
long if i'm going to define talent as
excellence at the highest level
over a long period of time for
continuity purposes in other words not a
flash in the pan not an overnight so
where are we going i'm going i'm going
with phil taylor right okay okay
yeah but talent is not ooh well
talented is someone who rewrote the
rules of their sport no one at nine dart
finished till phil taylor had it
properly done on tv live no one hit the
averages ever that phil talia and phil
taylor changed the whole landscape of
sport in the same way as tiger woods
changed the landscape of golf who is the
most famous person in your phone book
you probably
who is the next british world champion
in eddie's opinion
let me guess it'll be someone from your
table
all right let's go with connor ben what
is next for eddie after boxing
i think probably
some kind of major hollywood film
with you starring probably is it a live
story that would excite the general
public seriously i can see it
i've thought about a bit of music i
think we might might move in there have
you ever in your life
being accused of being delusional
you can't see me i mean 100 percent
broadcast i think you know but i can see
i can see the movies is terrifying you
wish you could have promoted yeah the
two fights the two trilogies that i
would have
desperate to be involved in would have
been obviously ali fraser
and walt getty those three fights were
unbelievable the the only disappointment
from my career was i never did eubank
been three because i would have loved to
have done it that would have been the
opening to pay-per-view shows in this
country and would have set a target
number that even fast car eddie hearn
couldn't match
if there's a fight you wish you'd made
but not quite quite got over the line
aj against deontay wilder for the
undisputed heavyweight championship
where would that have been eddie
wherever the most money was
yeah basically he's very consistent on
that
what
hello
imagine me going home again dave we've
got an issue here there's uh london or
there's five times more money for the
fighters to do it in saudi arabia or
london son
you've got to make sure you make it on
your home patch forget the money that's
definitely how i was brought up listen
to it
who is the better promoter eddie or
barry
you're a different club
yeah move on okay which sport does barry
think will be the next to go massive
well we've got our long-term projection
for the next five years is to work on
the support of nine ball pool because
it's a global sport and we're going to
make a lot of it and create a wonderful
global circuit but that's
i mean
i think sports got some really big
problems in this country over the next
10 years because less and less kids are
going to be playing sport because no one
wants to spend the time to dedicate
themselves to get better and better and
it's becoming of them and us situation
some kids have the opportunity others
don't and that's a disgrace for
government to sort out if you could take
over another football club who would it
be
oh
i wouldn't take over anyone
i would go back into lake norian rather
than take over another football club
that i have one club that's it not
interested in anything else end of
conversation up yours
[Laughter]
you can ask me that one
which fighter from the matron stable
past or present are you most proud of
what a good question to ask well done
i'm going to call out
for a little flyweight from ghana who
came over with nothing
that created himself as a little bit of
a boxer he went on one the british and
the commonwealth never earned a lot of
money
but saved every penny
great illustration to a fighters today
to be careful at the end of his career
where he fought twice for the world
title and got beat
he had a little bit of money saved up
and he bought some land in norfolk
his name is francis ampufo
and he is now the biggest egg supplier
in the country to marks and spencers
and that is the legacy i want to see
matrum leave to its fighters people that
learn along the way from us
and created sustainable businesses for
the benefit of their family
end of
it was trust me i learned it all from
him not
what was the proudest moment of your
career proudest moment of my career i
often get asked this question and it's
not easy to answer because obviously one
would think you know becoming champion
of the world but then of course
to defend the belt and come back to
manchester and bring the belt holes but
we'll go with manchester bringing the
balboa